flash flooding forced overnight rescues
outside Philadelphia this morning 52
million Americans are under the threat
of severe weather and they could see
heavy rain damaging winds and tornadoes
from a powerful storm system moving from
the south to the east Omar Villafranca
is in Greenville Texas that's about 45
miles outside Dallas Omar we understand
a possible tornado hit there overnight
good morning this was a tornado warned
storm but we won't know if this was
officially a tornado until the National
Weather Service comes out and surveys
the damage and this is some of the
damage they're gonna see later on this
morning we're here on one of the main
streets in Greenville this building the
walls were blown out you look over you
can see that there is twisted metal just
about everywhere you're looking not only
on the ground if you look up behind me
here you can see some of this is still
wrapped along the power poles good news
though no one was seriously injured but
there is plenty of damage severe storms
in the south unleashed high winds heavy
rains and baseball sized hail in parts
of Texas something came up with this
building went flying down the road and
then after that there was a crash over
here a possible tornado tore through
Greenville mangling several buildings
power lines and trees it's very sad to
see it like this
powerful winds tore parts of the roof
off this church our church building just
was like destroyed it crumbled in youth
group members Corbin Hudgens and Oscar
multiphase were trapped inside the roof
of our building Louis collapsed like
right in front of us and it started
coming down and then the water from
under that came under the door and start
flooding the place farther north
flash flooding slammed parts of Ohio
leaving several people trapped inside
their vehicles pretty much everything I
own is ruined and destroyed several
homes were damaged and many were forced
to evacuate by boat
Texas has taken a little bit of a
beating in the last few days there has
been severe weather in the Lone Star
State every day
since last Friday we'll get a little bit
of a break today hopefully they can
clean up some of this mess but of course
it is back tomorrow and then the severe
weather is expected to stretch from
Alabama all the way to New Jersey
through the weekend
Gayle oh boy and let's focus on today
though they get a little bit of a break
holding on to that thank you very much
Omar